안녕하세요 기슬롯 알렉입니다.
지난 강의 영상에 이어서 5장 얘기 드리도록 하겠습니다.
소프트웨어 공학과 아키텍처라는 타이틀은
여전히 개발 쪽에서, 또는 IT 분야에서
유효한 키워드라고 생각이 드는데요.
소프트웨어 공학이라는 것과 아키텍처를 제가 좀 묶었던 것은
이게 개발 방법론하고 그리고 구조 이런 얘기들이 같이 있어요.
그래서 한번 쭉 말씀을 드려보겠습니다.
소프트웨어 공학이 있고 아키텍처가 있는데 약간 별개이면서도
좀 관련이 좀 있을 수 있습니다.
자, 먼저 개발 방법론.
사실은 유효의 얘기를 이제 관심 있게 들으실 분이 있고
또 조금은 가볍게 보실 분들도 있을 것 같아요.
근데 이제 여기서부터 아키텍처 부분은
공통적으로 모두가 좀 생각을 했으면 하는 부분입니다.
개발 방법론은 특히 이 기업들에서 회사를 IT 회사,
컴퓨터 개발자로서의 IT 회사를 취업을 목표로 한다면
저는 좀 알아야 한다라고 생각하는 편이고요.
만약 1인 개발이나 자기가 AI로 본인이 직접 혼자 산다
그러면 개발 방법론이 아주 중요하다고 보이진 않아요.
물론 이런 CIC이나 이런 건 약간 둘 다 알면 좋죠.
그런 차원에서 보면 개발 방법론은
저는 개발을 잘 하는 방법들에 대한 얘기지만
조직에서 개발을 하기 위한 방법이기도 하다는 생각이 들어요.
원래 가장 전통적인 거는 폭포스라고 하죠. 이렇게 모양이고
이거가 대비돼서 많이 얘기 되는 것이 애자일
이런 모양을 가끔 볼 수 있습니다. 폭포스라는 것은 이렇게 기획하고
분석 설계하고
개발 테스트 이렇게 흘러간다고 해서 그 모양을 따라서 폭포스라고 한 것이고요.
사실은 애자일도 이러한 기획 분석 개발 테스트 단계를 거칩니다.
거칠 수밖에 없고요. 어떤 것을 만든다고 했을 때 이런 과정을 안 겪을 수는 없어요.
이 과정이 좀 짧게 지나가냐 아니면 좀 체계적으로 지나가냐 이런 차이가 있고요.
그래서 기획이라는 것은 말 그대로 무엇을 만들까 라는 것을 구상하는 단계 정도
그리고 계획도 좀 포함이 되고요. 그것을 분석하고 설계한다는 것은
어떻게 무엇이라는 관점을 조금 더 체계적으로 특히 설계는 이런 아키텍처 설계
소프트웨어 설계 시스템 아키텍처 이런 것들에 대한 설계도 포함이 되죠.
사실 건축물하고도 조금 연관이 있는 단어이에요.
아키텍처라는 것은 그래서 건축물의 모양을 어떻게 만들 것인가
이런 것과도 관계가 됩니다. 그래서 설계도라고 하죠.
건축물을 설계도는 되게 오차없이 정밀하게 하죠.
마찬가지로 개발할 때도 설계를 할 때 조금 정도는 다르지만 어느 정도 윤곽은 충분히 만들고 시작을 합니다.
그리고 개발하는 것이고 개발된 내용을 점검하는 것이 테스트죠.
이것을 이제 개발, 기획 개발 분석 설계라는 것을 조금 작은 사이클로 계속 돌아가는 것이 에자일이다 라고 좀 봐도 무방합니다.
그러니까 무슨 얘기냐면 이런 프로젝트들은 보통은 이렇게 발주로 해서 어떤 프로젝트
그러니까 어떤 것을 만드는 것으로 한 번 일회성으로 끝나는 일들을 이런 식으로 합니다.
보통 SI라는 표현도 많이 쓰고요.
그렇게 되는 것은 발주를 하고 납품이라고 하죠.
여기 납기까지의 시간이 있고 그 시간내에 요구되는 상 여기를 요구상이라고 해요.
요구상을 어떻게 개발할 것인지 쭉 정리하고 실제 개발해서 만들고 납품하는 이러한 그 프로젝트들에서 쓰는 방법
그러니까 지금도 많이 사용되는 거죠.
왜냐하면 이러한 일들이 있으니까 어떤 공공기관도 그렇고 어떤 회사들도 그렇고 이런 식으로 프로젝트를 발주하고 납품하는 것이 보통의 일들이긴 해요.
아이티스템을 만드는 일들에 반면에 서비스 회사들은 자기 자체의 서비스를 개발하다 보면
이런 식으로 어떤 일정을 딱 가지고 납품을 하고 끝나는 형태가 아니죠.
계속 만들어내죠.
그러니까 이게 기획하고 분석하고 설계하고 개발하고
사실 이쪽으로 넘어가면 여기서부터 시작될 수도 있고요.
계속 메비우스 D 같은 거니까.
근데 이거면 이제 이쪽이 운영하고 여기에 또 요구상을 수집할 수 있고
근데 여기서 조금 차이는 여기서는 요구상이란 표현보다는 사용자 시나리오 사용자 스토리
상황이 좀 다른 이유가 요구상이라는 것은 누군가 무엇을 요구하는 거잖아요.
사실은 이 서비스 회사에 요구를 할 사람은 없죠.
물론 사용자들의 어떤 요구상 사용자들이 어떤 것들에 대한 희망하는 기능들 이런 것들이 있다.
그걸 요구상이라고 하긴 그렇고 그런 것들을 쭉 수집하는 과정은 있지만 어쨌든 그런 얘기들을 쭉 듣고
다음에는 어떤 기능들을 만들겠다라고 해서 여기서는 백로구라는 표현을 씁니다.
약간 표현이 다른 거고 그리고 이렇게 한 번에 완전히 끝나는 게 아니라 이것을 이제 이런 식으로
어떤 주기를 갖고 스프린트라는 표현을 한대요.
주기를 갖고 한 번의 과정 이 한 번의 과정을 여기서 한 사이클로 맞춰지게 되는 거죠.
사실 이것은 반복이 뭐 끝이 없다고 볼 수도 있어요. 이것을 뭐 사주로 다니러 하느냐
그 차이는 무엇을 만드느냐 어떤 주기로 우리가 배포를 할 것이냐에 따라 다른 거죠.
그래도 사주만에 배포를 하더라도 여기는 납기라는 표현이 좀 더 맞고 여기는 배포가 좀 더 어울리겠죠.
배포를 하더라도 테스트까지 완전하게 돼야 되는 것은 동일합니다.
그러니까 이 한 사이클 안에 이게 다 들어가 있다라고 볼 수도 있는 거죠.
동일하게 하진 않을 수도 있어요. 예를 들면 기획 분석 설계를 조금 약식으로 한다든지
이렇게 대규모 프로젝트 꽤 긴 기간 동안 하는 것은 분석 설계가 굉장히 철저해야 돼요.
왜냐하면 이 폭포스라는 특징이 이렇게 떨어지고 나면 거슬러 올라가 굉장히 어렵습니다.
거슬러 올라간다는 것이 굉장히 어려워요.
그 대표적으로 코스트라는 표현을 쓰는데 코스트에는 비용도 있고 인건비도 있고 다 있어요.
인건비가 결국 비용일 수도 있지만 시간일 수도 있고요.
그 코스트라는 것이 뒤에 가면 갈수록 그거를 어떤 것을 바꾸는데
있어서 굉장히 높아져요.
그러니까 처음에 기획 단계에서 뭔가 기획이 변경되는 것은 바꾸면 되는 일인데
예를 들면 개발까지 다 됐는데 기획부터 바뀌어야 된다.
그럼 굉장히 많은 시간 또는 인건비 그런 것들이 또 추가적으로 된다는 거죠.
그렇기 때문에 이 한 단계 한 단계를 굉장히 철저하게 진행하는 거예요.
그런데 사주 스프린트 기준으로 한다면 일주일 이내로 기획 분석 설계가 되는 거고
그러다 보니까 조금 몇 개의 기능을 간단하게 설계할 수도 있고 기획할 수도 있다는 거예요.
특히 이게 이미 만들어진 상황에서의 추가 기능들일 수 있어서
이런 부분은 좀 되게 가볍게 하고 대신에 회기 테스트라든가 기존 거에 반영을 했을 때 문제가 없는지
전체적인 테스트가 조금 더 중요한 부분일 수 있는 거죠.
뭐 문화적인 부분, 스크럼을 한다, 데일리 스크럼 이런 식으로 표현도 하고
매일 아침에 잠깐 일어나서 서로의 일을 공유하고
이거는 문화적인 부분이 조금 더 크다고 봐요.
그것이 미국 문화나 이런 데서는 좀 자연스럽고
우리나라는 서비스를 잘 만들고 있는 회사들은 좀 안 차이 많이 됐는데
약간 우리나라 정사학은 좀 잘 안 맞습니다.
제가 애자리 영상도 하나 올렸는데
실제 꽤 큰 기업에서 애자리를 좀 해봤는데 어색해요.
잠깐 아이스브레이킹하고 자기 얘기를 한다는 게 되게 간단한 일인데
두 가지 우리에 빠져요.
그러니까 정말 애자리로 하자 해놓고 어떤 현상이 되냐면
데일리 스크럼을 한다고 하면 정말 5분, 10분 내에
간단하게 오늘 뭐할게요, 뭐할게요 이렇게 넣으면 좋은데
보통 그 회의가 돼버려요.
1시간짜리 회의가 되고
제가 심한 경우는 2시간씩 회의하는 경우는 봤어요.
그걸 원하는 게 아니었거든요.
잘못된 문화로 될 수 있다.
특히 우리나라 같이 회의를 정말
뭔가 회의 진심인 나라는 좀 그렇고
또 하나는 이 아이스브레이킹 과정이 되게 또 어색해요.
이게 과연 이 문화가 동일할까라는 생각이 좀 드는 면이 좀 있었어요.
하여튼 이거는 뭐 그 문화적인 분분이니까
그거보다는 이 본질에서 이 외 폭포수와 애자일
이렇게 좀 방법론들이 나왔나
그리고 내가 만약에 들어갈 회사가 서비스 회사다
그럼 애자일에 대해서는 조금 더 될 수 있게 더 알 필요가 있는 거고
왜냐하면 자꾸 그 얘기들을 해요. 그런 용어들을 쓰고
그랬을 때 뭐 백루그가 뭔지 뭐 이런 거
뭐 별거 아닌데 몰랐을 때는 당황할 수 있다는 거죠.
이것도 뭐 SI업이나 이런 거 할 때는 철저히 또 알아야 되는 부분이기 때문에
그런 것들이 있고
그랬을 때 이제 대법스는 여기에
여기하고 애자일하고 이렇게 됐고
대법스는 여기에 애자일과 좀 밀접합니다.
이거 자체가 대법스로 돌아가요.
여기가 이제 옵스고 대법.
그래서 개발과 오프레이션 운영이라는 것을 한대
심지어 팀도 같이 묶어요.
스쿼드라고 하는데 이 팀을 작은 단위로 묶돼
개발과 운영을 같이 하는 거죠.
그리고 배포도 심지어 그 단위로 합니다.
그래서 여기서 좀 주의있게 알아야 될 것들이 좀 있는 거예요.
스쿼드팀에서 배포 단위도 가져가고
심지어 그 스쿼드팀에서 언어나 플랫폼도 선정할 수가 있어요.
개발 프레임워크.
그러니까 프레임워크를 선정할 수 있어요.
그 팀이 상당한 자유도를 가져가요.
배포까지.
배포 주기도.
단 자율성이 있지만 책임도 있는.
뭐 그런 부분이 있고
또 하나는 배포에 대해서도 철제 독립적인.
그래서 다른 팀에 영향을 주면 안 되고
다른 팀이 배포될 때도 방어적으로 또 처리해야 될 부분들이 있고요.
이런 부분이 개발 방법론적인 부분이 되고요.
12D 컴퍼넌트 베이스드 개발론먼트인데
지금 잘 진화돼서 어딘가에 다 녹여져 있습니다.
컴퍼넌트라는 용어 굉장히 많고요.
또 MSA도 사실은
동일하다고 볼 수 전혀 없고
동일한 개념은 아니지만
사상은 좀 비슷해요.
컴퍼넌트 베이스라는 것도 집중되어서
특정 기능들을 모으자.
그래서 뭐 루줄리커플리드라는 표현도 거의 나오고
그 안에 되게 밀접하게 비주얼한 기능을 모아놓고
다른 컴퍼넌트 안에는 상당히 연관도를 좀 낮게 해서
그 집중을
좀 모은 다른 개념에서
MSA도 사실 기능을 모으고
그 기능 단위를 좀 나누는
마이크로 서비스 정도의 볼륨으로 나누는 개념이기 때문에
약간 사상은 좀 비슷하다.
그래서 MSA도 아키텍처 중에 하나이기 때문에
여기에 이제 설명 중에 포함이 됩니다.
그러면 이제 소프트웨어적인 아키텍처가 있고
시스템적인 아키텍처가 있다.
그리고 아키텍처를 잘 설계해야 된 이유
굉장히 중요한 부분이라고 생각하고
앞으로는 아니 지금도 그렇지만
아키텍처가 굉장히 중요한 역할이라고 생각해요.
그러니까 개발을 잘한다는 의미하고는
좀 약간 결이 다른 게
그리고 지금 개발은 어느 정도 많이
AI가 아무래도 대체될 수 있다고 보여주고
물론 아키텍처도 AI가 잘하죠.
잘하는데
질문을 또 잘해야 되는 역할이 있어요.
무조건 뭘 만들어 줘 한다고
아키텍처까지 알아서 다 잡아주지는 않기 때문에
그리고 경험해보셔서 이제 아시겠지만
AI한테는 질문의 방향만 살짝 틀어도
AI는 약간 그 질문에 맞춰주려고 하는 성향이 있어요.
그러니까 그렇게 하시면 안 되우라는 말을 잘 안 해요.
그런데 아키텍처는 이제 이런 거죠.
아키텍트가 사람이에요.
많이 헷갈리는 키워드
아키텍처와 아키텍트
아키텍처는 그 모습 자체
구성도 자체가 아키텍처고
아키텍트는 그것을 구성하는 사람이에요.
아키텍트는
저는 최고의 아키텍트는
그 소비자 또는 고객이
원하는 것을
가장 적고
가장 빠르게
가장 정확하게 만들어주는 사람
뭐 당연하고 이상적인 얘기는다는 거 알지만
이게 왜 중요하냐면
어떤 경우는 너무
너무 과해요.
저는 MSA를 얘기할 때마다 얘기하지만
MSA가 필요한 게 있고 아닌 게 있다 철저히
MSA면 좋을 게 있고
MSA면 더 안 좋을 게 있다.
그러면 서버 한 대가 필요한 게 있고
세대가 필요한 게 있고
또는 서버리스로 하는 것이 좋고
지금은 이제는
이것의 자유도가 너무 높아져서
이걸 쿠버네티스 기반으로 할지
서버리스로 할지
VM 하나 뛰어서 할지
그냥 컨테이너에다 할지
이거를 클란트에
일부 기능을 만들어서
서버비용을 좀 줄일지
이 모든 게 다 아키텍쳐예요.
그 아키텍처를 하나라고 말할 수 없어요.
그냥 구성도 그려주는 정도로
단순하게 생각할 수 없습니다.
AWS에서
뭐
뭐 룸드밸런스 그리고
뭐 뒤에 VM 그리고
뒤에 딥이 있어요.
그러니까 3 tier라고 하는데
3 tier도 아키텍쳐입니다.
그러니까 3 tier부터 시작이 돼요.
3 tier부터 알아야 되는 게
맞아요.
그 정석을 알아야 되고
그냥 굉장히 일반적인 것들에 대한
이기도 필요한 거고
제가 얘기하는 것은 궁극에
궁극에 가장 좋은 것을
제시할 수 있는 사람.
근데 가장 좋은 것이라고 해서
이제 두 가지 우류가 있어요.
약간 제가 이 책에
본 내용과는 좀 다른
책 같은 얘기를 좀 더 많이 하고 있는데
자 아키텍트의 우류 중에
저는 이런 게 있다고 봐요.
너무 장황하고
그러니까 기술만
많이 안다고 해서
그게 아키텍트냐
저는 그것의 우류가 있다.
그러니까 막 최신 기술 쓰면
최신 지금 막 나온 기술을
쓴다고
이게 능사 아니야.
그거 그리고 기술의 열거
그러니까 이것도 있고요.
저는 이 우류가 너무
너무 크다고 봐요.
그래서 아키텍트들이
화려한 언변이 있고
기술 많이 하니까 막 이것저것
막 얘기하는데 정작 필요한 거는
그 고객의 니지를
맞추는 거. 고객의
고객의 소리도 아니에요.
그러니까 고객의 요구상도
아니야 심지어.
그냥 고객의 본질적인 문제를
해결해주는 사람.
저는 그거라고 보거든요.
서버를 만들어주세요. 서버를 만들어주세요. 계속하고 있는데
사실 그건 서버를 만들 것도 아니야.
이런 경우도 심지어
그 정확한
요구의
본질을 찾아서
맞춰주는 사람이 궁극에
좀 아키텍트라고
생각을 합니다.
비슷한 결인데
최신 기술 많다.
최신과 비슷한데
복잡하다고 좋다라고
조금 오해하는 거
그러니까
MSA가 MSA를 알았어요.
MSA 좋은 것도 있어요. 분명히 있어요.
MSA로 서비스를
만들어요.
어쩌면 당연한 얘기인데
근데 이제 지금
만들려고 하는 것이
스타트업에서 예를 들면
이제 막 서비스를 시작하려고요.
그러면 서버 한 대어도 돼요.
왜냐하면 그 서비스가 폭주하는 것도
아니고
서비스의 기능을 3분에서
할 수 있는데
부적종적으로 MSA다
물론 초반에 잘 만들어놓으면
확장성이 있다는 거 충분히 맞는 얘기죠.
하지만 지금 그런
상황인지가 더 문제인 거죠.
그러니까
저도 예를 들면 서버를
서비스 오픈하고 이중화를 해놨다고요.
이중화야 어렵지 않고
어쩌면 당연하게 생각하는 거고
당연히 해야 되지만
이중화 마저도 필요 없더라고요.
왜냐하면 이중화도 서버인데
API의 쿨이 없는데
이중화 한들 뭐 해요.
그러니까 지금에 맞는 거
그러니까 지금의 상황에 맞는
것을 제시하고
향후의 확장성을 고려해주면 되는 거죠.
소프트웨어적인 아키텍처는
소프트웨어를 얘기하는 거고요. 말 그대로
소프트웨어를 어떻게
모주라 해서 어떤 식으로 배치할 것인가
컴포헌트 단위
이런 것들
이것도 사실 되게
심오한 여유이죠.
설계하는 것도 일종의
아키텍처인 거고. 소프트웨어적인.
시스템을 한다는 것은
웨어버스 DB가 기본적이라면
그것들이
조금 더 복잡해져서
예를 들면 MSA가 될 수도 있는 거고
메시지큐, MSA에 필요한
미드로여기도 하고
메시지큐를 도입할 수도 있고
캐시를 쓸 수도 있고.
요즘 AWS, 클라우드를 쓴다면
클라우드에 여러가지의
서비스를 좀 엮으면
굉장히 효율적으로
풀 수도 있는 부분도 있죠.
그런 것들을
아키텍터가 하는 일이고
그런 것들을 아키텍터 설계한다고
하는데
AWS의 솔루션 아키텍터들이
그런 일을 합니다. 아키텍트들이
저도 좀 말하면서 좀 헷갈렸는데
아키텍트들이
솔루션 아키텍트라는 것은
어떤 솔루션을 썼을 때
굉장히 적합하다. 이런 것들을
고개 요구를 딱 듣고
주는 거죠. 그런 일들을 한다는 거예요.
저는 그래서
어쩌면 AI가
굉장히 많이 자리 잡을 때
여전히도 조금은
희소하게 계속적인 역할을 할 수 있는 것이
이런 아키텍트들이
아닐까
하는 생각도 좀 해봅니다.
여전히 좀 필요한 부분. 그리고
아키텍터 설계를 왜 잘해야 되냐면
결국 이것에 의해서
개발도 조금씩 바뀔 수 있고
그것이 확장성이 있냐도 문제고
그리고 이중화라는 것들을 통해서
안정성도 보장이 되고
그러니까 아키텍터 할 일이
아키텍터 구성에 있어서
굉장히 중요한 부분들. 아키텍터가
이 어떤
서비스를 만듦에 있어서
굉장히 중요한 역할을 차지한다 라고
볼 수가 있습니다.
이쪽이
드벨러먼트고 계획을 하고
개발을 하고요. 빌드
빌드는 개발된
소스들을 묶는 거예요. 묶고
그것들을 실제
실행될 수 있는 형태로 만드는 과정
그리고 테스트를 진행하고
테스트가 어느 정도 통과되면
여기서 릴리즈라는 것은
운영 쪽에
전달할 파일
릴리즈 파일이라고도 하고
요거를 디플로이 한다고 해서
배포. 배포는
실제 시스테만의
지금 만든 프로그램이 탑재되는 과정
릴리즈 파일을 실행 서버
운영 서버에
그런 부분이 배포예요
디플로이
그리고 운영을 하는 거예요. 운영을 하고
문제가 있는지 모니터링하고
운영팀에서 좀 하고
개발팀에서 하고
대법스는 이러한데
진정으로는 이걸 팀을 하나로 묶어요
그래서
스커드팀이라고 해서 개발과 운영을
같이 합니다.
그런 식으로까지 같이
하는 형태로 만들어지는
그것들을
이런 형태를 만들어 가기 위한 방법론
중에 하나인 거고요
소프트웨어공학과
아키텍처 내용
이 정도로 좀 말씀드리겠습니다.
이게 내용이 좀 많아져가지고
끊고 다음에 컴퓨터 구조라든가
이런 부분을
말씀을 드리겠습니다.